and finally as the saying goes some news
about me after 15 years this is my final
program for Sky News the best
organization in the UK which you already
know for its coverage and Analysis and
also it's dedicated inventive
hard-working staff so many of whom have
become close friends and I want to say
thanks to you all for putting up with me
and supporting me so resolutely through
elections resigning Prime Ministers and
Monarch's funerals but of course my
greatest Thanks goes to you the viewers
you make Sky News you are Sky News your
engagement encouragement and feedback
have been invaluable over my time here I
hope that I've managed to serve you well
it has been an absolute privilege thanks
for making this career so worthwhile I
leave you with always wanted to do this
a last look at the headlines
there they are
You Stay classy planet Earth
goodbye
[Applause]